نحن هنا في ميناء اسكندرون التابع لمحافظه
عطاء هذه المحافظه التي تضررت بشكل كبير
جراز زلزال الذي ضرب تركيا المشافي كانت
جزءا من هذه الاضرار وبالتالي حتى يتم
المساعده في الحاله الصحيه تم تحويل هذه
السفينه التي نحن سندخل اليها الان الى
مشفى ميداني هذا المشفى ساهم خلال الايام
الماضيه في المساعده على علاج الحالات
الصحيه هنا في محافظه هاتاي خصوصا وانا
المشافي في تلك المحافظه تضررت بشكل كبير
نحن الان دخلنا هذه السفينه التي تحولت
الى مشفى هنا مدخل السفينه ساسير الى
الامام لنرى هناك قسم تسجيل المرضى
والمرافقين لهم هذه المشفى خلال الايام
التي اعاقبت الزلزال
ساهمت في علاج اكثر من 4000 مريض جاؤوا من
مختلف المناطق المتضرره طبعا هذه المشفى
هي لم تكن مخصصه فقط من اجل الذين اصيبوا
في الزلزال وانما هي تحولت الى مشفى شانها
شان كل المشافي تستقبل كل الحالات واحده
من الحالات كانت هنا لولاده ربما وهذا امر
لافت ان تجري ولاده على متن سفينه بحريه
وايضا كان هناك العديد من الحالات الاخرى
هناك اختصاصات قلبيه هناك اختصاصات
للاطفال اختصاصات جراحه كل ذلك لدى هذه
المشفى كما اخبرنا القائمون عليها المشفى
البحري هناك العديد من الاجهزه وهي تقوم
مقام المشافي ربما في الحالات الطارئه
كونها مشفى ميداني نستطيع ان نرى هنا
تقسيم هذه الاقسام
لكل ما يمكن
الاحتياج اليه ساحاول النظر هنا ربما هذا
المكان ربما فيه بعض الادويه
الاساسيه التي يمكن استخدامها ايضا لدينا
هنا ربما نشاهد في هذا القسم جهاز الايكو
لاستقبال الحالات التي تحتاج الى تصوير
صوتي وهذا القسم هنا هو مكتوب عليه انه
مجال الاحمر او الموقع الاحمر وهو للحالات
الحرجه اي ان الحاله اذا كانت حرجه جدا
اول ما يتم التعامل معها يتم التعامل معها
في هذا القسم تحديدا ومن ثم يتم نقلها الى
الاماكن الاخرى هناك العديد من الاقسام
الاخرى ايضا هنا تصوير ربما
نعم هذا المكان ايضا فيه اجهزه تصوير
نستطيع ان نشاهد ذلك
هنا في هذا المكان
ايضا هناك
العديد من الاسره في هذا المشفى تقريبا
يوجد 120 سريرا استطيع ان ارى هناك ربما
بعض المرضى الذين بقوا في هذا المكان
نستطيع ان نشاهد هنا بعض المرضى وهم ليسوا
جميعا من مناطق الزلزال لكن ايضا من
المناطق التي تحتاج الى مشافي كون المشافي
تضررت بشكل كبير شكرا يمكن القول ان هذه
المشفى ساهمت في المساعده في الحاله
الطبيه
للمتضررين بالزلزال وهذه ايضا هي هذه
المشفى هي تابعه للقوات البحريه التركيه
شكرا المعتز بالله حسن من ميناء اسكندرون
من داخل سفينه انزال حولت الى مشفى لانقاذ
الجرحى من زلزال كهرمان شكرا لك